fantastic from tv shows like the crown
to her cameo with paddington bear we
showed it to you earlier queen elizabeth
is being celebrated for her influence
and her appearances in music and in
popular culture sir paul mccartney
joined other music greats in honoring
her yesterday and overnight tweeting god
bless queen elizabeth ii may she rest in
peace
long live the king
gail spoke with sir mccartney earlier
this year about his meeting with the
queen at the height of beatlemania
did you ever dream of meeting her even
think that it would be a possibility no
yeah of course not because you know
we're just working class boys and she's
the queen
so there's
an ocean or two between us so i never
thought i would till we became the
beatles yeah and we got
rather famous yeah rather
[Music]
this queen was clearly in tune with
these times
her majesty understood
these musical ambassadors were the
hottest british export since shakespeare
she was criticized for it but in 1965
the queen made them the first rock stars
to be honored at buckingham palace a new
big swanky car pulls through the palace
gates
and you're inside so what were you told
to do so you told to not shake a hand
call her ma'am
not your majesty
and you know if she stops on the line
and talks to you
talk to her otherwise otherwise shut up
[Laughter]
otherwise shut up shut up mark phillips
joins us now from buckingham palace uh
mark good morning again i know the queen
was a lover of the arts but she also
appeared in many many shows and movies
and uh didn't always have control over
the narrative i can't imagine she loved
every bit of it good morning
good morning i'd call her more of a
patron of the arts more than a lover of
the arts there's a certain irony in
connection with the queen and the whole
cultural history
you know 70 years of which passed well
she was on the throne here and that is
that almost none of it seemed to
actually touch her
the swinging 60s
rock and roll
punk everything that's happened since
she acknowledged it she would appear at
variety performances pop cultural
performances and that kind of thing she
was the patron of national theater
groups and that kind of thing but we
never knew
just what sort of music she liked just
what sort of art she liked that really
wasn't part of the public presonic
persona of her and it may have been for
a reason it may have been because she
didn't want to show a preference for one
type uh or the other when paul mccartney
talks about the beatles
the book is out just as to how much how
many so how many lyrics she could have
repeated uh of beatles songs even in
their heyday here but it was part of her
general persona as i say that
she she encouraged the production of
british culture she recognized the role
the soft power if you will of british
culture as it was exported to the world
just as she recognized her own soft
power in terms of the kind of influence
that she could have
a lot of activity going on behind you
mark the mallets and the rubber spikes
have come out i think yeah
that something has happened but it was
interesting mark even uh mick jagger
tweeted about the queen
even he weighed in talking about the
queen i love that yeah i mean
well you know every everybody loved her
from all walks of life all walks of
culture uh it's still a work in progress
here as you can see
um but there's but there's there's some
questions to as to how much of it she
actually particularly you may have it
was i think two jubilees ago when brian
may of queen played god save the queen
from the from the ramparts of the palace
and what have you and i think there's a
funny paul mccartney story about that
too when uh she thanked them for coming
and and and he said well great we'll be
back next year and she said no
mark phillips i love your red glasses
legacy lasts forever i love them as well
mark thank you very much no